bonsoir yannick mireur merci d'être avec
nous est ce que vous êtes surpris par la
tournure de cette élection au de
l'élection elle même
évidemment parce que c'était assez serré
c'est un regain de participation
extraordinaire des voix gagnées par
millions par les deux candidats
même séparés par un vote populaire au
qui tourne autour de 5 millions de voix
mais comment dirais-je un rattrapage les
candidats démocrates précisément ce qui
au moins là il n'y en a pas eu d'erreur
sur les prédictions grâce au vote par
correspondance qu'il y aura en effet et
tous expliquent largement bénéficié et
puis une sorte de résistance un petit
peu futiles pour tout dire du président
sortant puisque je ne pense pas que ce
soit un bras de fer je pense que l'
affaire est entendue et que de la même
manière qu'eux avec une certaine
désinvolture
monsieur trump et aller jouer au golf et
bien de son côté messieurs maiden se met
au travail
il n'est pas question de démocrates et
de républicains de 30 cours de bail
donne simplement il ya une élection il
ya un gagnant il ya un pays qui traverse
une crise sanitaire qui n'a pas été
prise au sérieux par la précédente
administration
donc il est urgent de mettre en oeuvre
un plan sanitaire fédérale qui coordonne
l'action des états diffuser
l'information
bénédicte fiable aux citoyens américains
etc
c'est ça l'urgence est donc une est un
petit peu navrant embarrassant c'est
vrai je reprends le mot du président élu
que la situation soit celle qu'elle est
devant nous mais je ne pense pas qu'il
ira chaos non plus je pense que
il ya des échéances une écembre le 14
décembre pour la réunion du collège
électoral cetera d'ici là les les
résultats sont tout à fait connu entre
temps pas plus que des derniers jours
les recours déposés par les organismes
républicain dans les états où la
campagne du candidat trump n'a eu gain
de cause puisqu'il s'agit de contester
l'enregistrement de certains le bulletin
de vote après une certaine heure par
rapport à la règle de l'état de
contester usage de stabilo boss
il ya eu toute une petite une
conspiration sur les réseaux sociaux là
dessus sur l'usagé stabilo boss plutôt
que des stylos à pointe
bref et le monsieur raphaël guère que
vous venez de faire voir secrétaire
d'état c'est à dire le ministre de
l'intérieur lisons de géorgie est un
républicain et donc s'il y avait une
véritable faute fraude là où en
pennsylvanie de manière aussi massive
que ce serait nécessaire pour qu'il y
ait changement de résultat ça se verrait
assez facilement donc tout ceci n'est
pas très surprenant et je pense que si
l'on en croit les rumeurs la famille
l'entourage de monsieur tron lui-même se
divisent avec celui le seul qui a eu des
fonctions officielles maison blanche son
gendre qui semble qu'il tendrait à
essayer de le convaincre de jeter
l'épongé il y aurait intérêt puisque
rien ne changera monsieur ben laden est
le 46e président des états unis et il
aurait plutôt intérêt lui-même à sortir
sinon élégamment ça m'étonnerait
beaucoup mais en tous les cas devenir
raisonnable de cette situation alors
beaucoup en tout cas yannick mireur
parle du déni du président trump est ce
que c'est vraiment la bonne analyse
qu'il faut avoir c'est du déni ou tout
simplement c'est une stratégie
de la part du président républicain je
pense qu'il n'est pas fou j'essayais pas
d'une question de déni il était possible
dans les premières heures ça peut se ça
peut se concevoir
mais au point où on en est où toutes les
chancelleries du monde entier les unes
après les autres
félicite le candidat au moment où aussi
un ancien président aux états unis
monsieur bush républicain la féliciter
monsieur byden est aussi avancée il a
fait plus que si je puis me permettre le
service minimum le président bush il a
aussi déclaré très clairement que le
processus électoral aux états unis avait
été parfaitement transparent qu'il n'y
avait pas lieu de s'inquiéter de fraudes
massives sinon de petites irrégularités
ici là ça arrive même en france où ou
ailleurs je crois que n'est plus
question de nier aujourd'hui c'est plus
une question de tactique ou de stratégie
j'ai du mal à y voir clair d'ailleurs là
dedans mais monsieur trêve nous avait
habitués à des choses très erratique et
contradictoires toutes les chancelleries
pardonnez moi vous dites toutes les
chancelleries les unes après les autres
le féliciter quand même pas le cas de
tout le monde à tout le monde n'a pas
félicité israël a salué joe biden n'a
pas félicité la russie la chine certains
attendent des résultats officiels
puisque à partir du moment où l'on
demande un recomptage qu'il est en droit
de faire même s'il a peut-être peu de
chances de l'emporter
et bien c'est compliqué de le féliciter
n'est ce pas non vous n'avez n'adhérez
pas en tout cas cette ce postulat non je
joue je crois je ne crois pas je pense
que les pays notamment les alliés
traditionnels des états unis france
allemagne canada angleterre
pourtant dieu sait si on a bien close et
sur l'amitié particulière entre monsieur
johnson et monsieur train ou leur façon
de voir les choses d'une manière
semblable bref monsieur johnson n'a pas
perdu de temps pour reconnaître la
situation
je ne crois pas les vins la turquie
aussi l'a fait donc tout confondu
démocratie représentative origines plus
autoritaire donc la chose et la chose
est avancé et pour ce qui est des
recours vous absolument ils sont tout à
fait légaux comme je vous le dit tout à
l'heure il ya des dates et je pense que
monsieur trump devrait jouer sur ces
dates mais au lieu d'un mois ou un mois
et demi il n'y a plus guère de
possibilité puisque les résultats sont
rendus s'agissant par exemple de la
géorgie la géorgie avait déjà que ça
fait partie de son code électoral notre
correspondant l'a rappelé la marge de
2,2 différence entre les deux candidats
est tel 05 % qu'elle accueillit
automatiquement un recomptage des voix
mais on sait aussi qu historiquement le
recomptage des voix ne livre guère de
surprise d'autant que si vous regardez
les chiffres n'ont pas la proportion de
différences entre les deux mais le
nombre de bulletins que cela concerne
plus de dix mille bulletins
c'est difficile de concevoir une erreur
sur 10000 butin est donc l'histoire
montre que lorsqu'il ya un recomptage
mais bien souvent c'est le même résultat
qui en ressort
beaucoup d'américains nous disait sur
place que finalement le pire aujourd'hui
aux etats-unis c'était cette division et
qu'ils espéraient
dans cette élection que ces divisions
sais c'est ce que justement les derniers
développements vont en ce sens est ce
qu'on peut décemment être optimiste
écoutez il par nature je le suis il faut
espérer qu'avec sa longue expérience et
la faiblesse de sa candidature mais la
période extraordinaire qu'il traverse
dans sa vie monsieur byden saura trouver
les mots je dirais que son discours
jusque-là d'apaisement de conciliation
nationale était celui qu'il fallait il
est regrettable que monsieur tron peu
n'est pas une attitude comparables
ensuite il faut se projeter plus loin il
y aura une administration démocrate
baleine pendant les quatre ans qui
viennent
la question est de savoir quel sera
l'héritage de monsieur trump qui a su
parler à des classes populaires et
moyennes
méprisé négligées ou oubliées temps par
la droite du parti républicain que par
la gauche du parti démocrate
c'est cet héritage là qui me semble
salutaire même s'il l'a fait et de
manière très abrasives emportant la
division au sein du pays
mais c'est une intuition juste qu'il a
eue de la même manière au plan
international sur la chine par exemple
maintenant il ya consensus dans la
classe politique et les affaires aux
états unis pour être assez ferme
vis-à-vis de la chine
donc la question de savoir comment son
héritage surtout en politique intérieure
si c'est votre question va se décliner
quelle sera l'attitude l'orientation du
parti républicain et de la même manière
du côté démocrate puisque ce sont deux
parties qui sont un petit peu comme si
non des canard sans tête en tous les cas
sont depuis bien longtemps maintenant
divisée manque de leadership le cohésion
et de élevé de projets et nationale a
proposé aux américains et donc c'est
seulement ce travail là de part et
d'autre qui permettra je pense de da
d'atténuer cette polarisation dans le
climat que nous connaissons je pense que
les états unis pourront pourrons
surmonter cela mais c'est la
responsabilité de monsieur byden et des
leaders républicains en particulier au
sénat merci yannick mireur politologue
spécialiste des états unis d'avoir été
avec nous